all right so we actually haven't talked
much about isis over the last couple
weeks because there's been all kinds of
other news and now obviously what just
happened in france but isis is still up
to a lot of really really awful [ __ ] and
of course we are still
in a war now in syria that we have no
congressional authorization over but we
don't really talk about that
but anyway a couple of new images came
out uh that i thought were
pretty disturbing and the type of [ __ ]
that people need to see to understand
really what's happening there
this is isis they are chopping off the
hand
of a man who uh who stole some stuff
that's all he stole some stuff so they
are chopping
off his hand um and so you can see he's
sitting in a chair he's got a noose tied
to his wrist
and that's how they pull the hand away
after it's chopped off
uh next photo isis law demands that
after a trial a list
of the criminals crimes be read out
front of a in a crowd of men who have
been invited to watch before the
punishment
is carried out so there they're doing
some chopping it's pretty awful
uh there are unblurred versions of this
by the way yeah we we blurred this
because we can't show it it's really
quite awful um of course here's the
moment that they cut off his hand
uh the next uh yeah this is just a group
of people i mean this is just becoming
the norm
in the places that they control that
these types of public executions and
mutilations and all this awful stuff
this was about a week before
where a man was whipped for watching
porn so he's being publicly whipped for
watching porn
we've got another one on that and uh as
is customary in
the islamic state punishment propaganda
the final photograph
appears to be a stage scene where the
victim is shown hugging the isis fighter
who has just punished him as an act of
forgiveness
so in a weird way like as horrible as
all the
the stuff that we're showing you is that
almost seems like the worst part of it
like then they're like oh thank you for
correcting my ways
um so i guess my first question here is
uh this sort of goes to what i asked you
in the france thing a little while ago
but
does anything shock us anymore we've
already seen beheadings we've seen
videos of beheadings
we've seen literally heads on sticks i
mean really
horrific [ __ ] and now this is just
another extension of that right
yeah that shocked me i don't know what
i'm gonna do about it but it definitely
is like
what the [ __ ] are you doing yeah
like what is this accomplished move to
the islamic state
it's gorgeous here we'll cut your hand
off and smack you in the back in front
of your mom for watching porn
and you will thank us for it yeah that's
a good idea you that's the parody that
you should be doing
yeah is the tourism board for isis uh
really are you shocked by anything at
this point
it was horrible and also you need to
think about i'm shocked that they think
that this is going to stop people from
watching porn people watch porn and if
you look at the data
a lot of these countries are heavy
consumers of internet porn
yeah not only the heavy consumers of
internet porn but i think our fourth
most watched country for this show is
saudi arabia
which i think is really kind of
fascinating because they're so insanely
repressed
even though they're apparently a big
ally of the united states we give them a
lot of money we do all kinds of security
stuff with them sure women can't drive a
vote but you know whatever
uh but they can't drive here am i right
yeah
um so i'm going to take i'm going to
take this one
you should that could have been deserve
that that kind of a strong edge it was
just a
slight push it could have been a full
more smack mode
um so with all the crazy [ __ ] that we
have going on with our police here
and you know the authoritative state and
all that stuff
does this kind of put it a little bit
into perspective about how horrible the
world is
uh yeah it does put it in perspective
that doesn't mean we shouldn't stop like
fighting no of course it's a more
perfect union but yeah it does i mean
it's like
i'm so happy that i live here you know
yeah i'm so happy
that's what i mean do we forget that a
little bit of course i'm not defending
any surveillance state or any of that
[ __ ] which we
relentlessly attack here all the time
but a little bit of that do we forget
like that we actually do
have it pretty good yes it's a [ __ ] up
system we have racial inequality and
financial inequality and all that but
like it's still it's pretty good here
right it's like when you're and
you go to your thanksgiving dinner and
you're like oh my family's crazy
and then that one time you're like out
of town and you go to someone else's
you're like no these people are [ __ ]
up
yeah that's what it feels like yeah i
can't i can't
imagine like anyone wanting to
you know what we have in america
hopefully is like a country people want
to live in
yeah and that's you know for all the
[ __ ] that's messed up about it
we kind of want to make it cool yeah you
know it's like we
decorate the place make it fancy but
there it's like oh
what is appealing about that what is
appealing about a place where they cut
your
hand off and you don't have a hand for
the rest of your life
because you stole like something from
blockbuster i don't know whatever the
equivalent is
but i'm sure it's a blockbuster
equivalent as opposed to a netflix right
uh do you have an answer for that what
is this what is the tourism
brett but like i don't know for us
i don't know we do have a prison system
but in that prison system it's like we
don't like cruel and unusual punishment
because like
carrying and feathering was weird we
have serious problems with
our prison system and absolutely
prisoners
you know that does not diminish um with
the knowledge that there are
horrible disgusting people doing
like just horrible things to other
people like that yeah
we are lucky in a sense but that doesn't
mean we shouldn't we should stop
striving to always be
no of course of course i think that goes
without saying that of course we can do
better and we should do better
uh and all that but does it is do you
take when you look at this stuff
like to me this is the irony of america
like everyone loves to hate us and we
love to
to you know make fun of the system and
all that but without us
also like when [ __ ] goes down everybody
also wants us there
so is this like the ultimate irony of
american
life i mean yes that it is but like
there's also another interpretation of
that where it's like
oh my god america is that crazy neighbor
with the gun
we don't want to have to go there at all
we don't want to we don't want to have
to talk to them
we don't want to invite them to dinner
because they'll be like
and we'll go shoot stuff in the backyard
like at least that's the perception of
it yeah
so they that still doesn't mean that i
mean they need us because we got a big
gun
but like that's it isn't necessarily
everything about us that they
that they like that led to that right
all right well can we at least all agree
that hand chopping off bad
whipping for porn bad am i right kim
orchard that's right unless that's part
of the porn and you like it
[Music]